let's talk about arguments it's usually
the case that a conclusion a claim an
assertion can't stand on its own
it needs something to hold it up
supporting it and that's what we call an
argument an argument is a reason or a
set of reasons that are meant to uphold
a conclusion an argument is your
explanation of how you arrived at your
conclusion so an argument can be thought
of as a set of statements that justify a
new statement the statements of your
argument are called premises premise the
david pakman show studio is located in
Boston premise Boston is in
Massachusetts conclusion the david
pakman show studio is in Massachusetts
this is an argument this is also an
example of a deductive argument a
deductive argument is an argument
wherein the premises guarantee the
conclusion if our studio is located in
Boston and Boston is located in
Massachusetts our studio must be located
in Massachusetts it's a deductive
argument because the premises expressed
in the argument alone give you enough to
determine to deduce the conclusion the
conclusion that our studio is in Boston
must follow the premises that are given
no new premises that could be added to
this argument could change its validity
and given these two premises this will
always be the conclusion but what if I
said this premise our channel has been
releasing new YouTube videos every week
for the last X years however many it's
been conclusion our channel will have
new episodes this week does my premise
support my conclusion yeah the premise
gives me good reason to think that my
conclusion is true that the david pakman
show will release new YouTube videos
this week but this is no longer a
deductive argument we would call this an
AmpliTube argument also known as an
inductive argument this is because my
premise makes my conclusion probable but
the premise does not guarantee the
conclusion there
new potential premises that could
invalidate the argument for example
YouTube has been hacked by the Russians
and the site has been taken offline for
a month so no we're not going to be
uploading new videos so the premises of
a deductive argument guarantee the
conclusion no matter what other premises
are added and a strong inductive
argument has premises that suggest that
the conclusion is probably true but
other premises could be added that would
invalidate the argument if someone is
intending their argument to be deductive
but their conclusion is not guaranteed
by their premises then you know it's a
bad argument and not just AmpliTube
deductive arguments are based on
objectivity and inevitability ampliative
arguments allow for more flexibility but
require proper inference deductive
arguments have the advantage of giving
us everything we need to know simply
within our premises even if implicitly
it's concerned with testing and
confirming a hypothesis and this plays
an important role in math and science
especially the hard sciences but it's
inductive reasoning and ampliative
arguments that allow for creative
thinking and consideration for what if
think of practicing medicine and
diagnosing a disease or solving economic
problems or developing a marketing
strategy while inductive reasoning
creates a risk for loss of objectivity
it pays off by making use of more
open-ended thinking and problem-solving
and consideration for outside factors
and possibilities which are crucial to
countless fields do you want to get
better at debating people you should
check out one of my favorite online
learning portals brilliant which
sponsors our critical thinking mini
series brilliant has fascinating
hands-on lessons that allow you to think
and argue more clearly about political
and philosophical issues check out their
lessons on logic rationality multi-level
thinking ident
find false information and identifying
fallacies it's a vibrant community of
over five million members it brings
together the expert knowledge and
experience of students educators and
professionals from all over the world to
create an immersive interactive online
learning environment keeping up with the
news is one thing but you're never
really fully equipped to understand
politics until you've developed a
complete understanding about how the
world at the most fundamental levels
works sign up for free by going to
brilliant org slash critical thinking
I've put a link in the description under
this video and the first 200 people who
visit will get 20% off an annual Premium
Membership visit brilliant org slash
critical thinking